si vous êtes streamer si vous êtes
professeur si vous êtes professionnel
j'ai un produit qui est vraiment fait
pour vous c'est celui là qui la dette
représentait qui vient de sortir en tout
cas c'est un produit d'in-stat 360
céline stade 360 links et une webcam
intelligente 4k 30 fps on va tous
détails et c'est aujourd'hui deux vidéos
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec un
stage stein stagiaire est à 360 qui m'a
proposée tient monsieur consorts une
nouvelle webcam qui est super
intéressante pour tous ceux qui ont
besoin d'un produit hyper intelligent
qui va pouvoir venir vous suivent qui va
vous traquez il ya plein de super
fonctionnalités derrière si cette caméra
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien en
bas dans la description pour pouvoir
vous faire plaisir je le vis tu la
mettes par la tête oui donc ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui est bien c'est que on
va ouvrir on va la regarder on va tester
en donner le retour complet et ça c'est
cool vous est pris on y va banco
[Musique]
alors ça se passe là j'ai deux produits
g la caméra en elle-même qui est juste
la banque et je vous passe très
rapidement la boîte un terrain
artificiel très gros focus qu'ils ont
fait ici la 4k ça c'est cool bon la
boîte c'est assez standard on passe très
rapidement après j'ai un tripode un truc
qui est intéressant ici c'est que la
webcam je peux venir éclipsé directement
sur un ordinateur comme il vous le
montre la regarde et vous venez là
mettre directement sur un pc ou un mac
ça c'est bien mais si vous voulez faire
d'autres choses ou pouvait faire des
choses notamment la posé sur un trépied
ça vous permet de la poser à côté d'un
ordinateur si vous souhaitez pour avoir
un autre plan et ça vous permet
également d'avoir une vue du dessus si
par exemple comme moi tout de suite
voulu manipuler des objets donc ça c'est
très cool ça permet d'avoir un truc est
extrêmement flexible et puis mon be1
timo des trucs sympathiques 5 you for
meeting with pleasure une star 360 on a
quelques spec ici on regarde très très
rapidement capteur 1/2 pousuivi assassi
coup ça je voulais 10 trous focus en
effet vraiment le focus sur vous double
micro à réduction de bruit ça c'est cool
contrôlant jeunesse vous allez voir on
fait déjà 10 à contrôler la caméra le
mode portrait mode table blanc mode vie
privée il y en a tous les côtés des
conseils de pros enfin bref ça c'est
cool donc on se regarde ça tout de suite
bien évidemment et puis c'est quoi ça
adventure hockey timos a pas bref donc
vous êtes prêt on y va on commence par
l'one boxing alors on en boxe comme
d'hab on prend et on secoue des produits
pour les hommes boxaient la webcam en
elle-même ok touch qui alors attendez on
va y aller un peu plus doucement je
pense que je la sors ah ouais c'est
vraiment tout petit tout petit tout
petit pour l'instant je laissais film
plastique ici pour venir le protéger
l'aïe a écrit quatre qu'avec l'ouverture
de f 1.8 donc ça en termes de faible
luminosité c'est vachement bien d'avoir
cette couverture là ça je peux venir le
retirer caméras font céder des petits
micros que je dois avoir de vent juste
la prise usb c'est pour venir la
connecter il aurait ici j'ai un petit
peu de vie c'est du un quart de pouce
donc c'est pareil je peux venir de coûts
pour la mettre sur le pied je pense que
c'est pratique et si vous avez aussi
d'autres pied pour venir l'adapter
dessus alors dans les jeux louvre comme
ça et je pense que ensuite ouais comme
il nous montre un peu ici je la prends
comme ça et je vais le clip c'est comme
ça sur un ordinateur et après elle comme
elle est totalement orientable alvergnat
se positionner pour vous reconnaîtrez
vous suivre ton petit module pratique
discret fin ok je vois qu'ici j'ai un
coin avec des accessoires alors qu'est
ce qu'il ya comme un accessoire
là dedans accessoires boxe le voir alors
accessoires qu'est-ce que ça c'est quoi
cordon usb c'est usb c'est donc pour
venir se brancher sur un ordinateur pc
mac ces pratiques alors l'aja
l'adaptateur pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'usb c'est aura aujourd'hui mais qui
ont de l'usb a comme ça je peux bien
branché hop là mon usb c'est directement
dessus et je le passe sur une prise usb
alors ça c'est l'outil un peu
indispensable comme on l'est sur une
petite webcam qu'on peut emmener je
pense très facilement si vous voulez
stream et de jeunes saison et bien c'est
pareil on va voir le petit étui c1 et 8
mai c'est pas du tout a dit oui tu
déconnes monsieur ça ça sert à venir à
la nettoyer oui mais toi peuple à plat
devant ça s'est bien allongé pas
d'étudiants faites attention si vous
voulez venir l'emmener avec vous et vous
avez ça également dans la boîte alors ça
en fait c'est pas des autocollants sait
des choses que vous allez mettre sur un
tableau blanc parce qu'il ya un mode
tableau blanc si par exemple vous êtes
professeur et que vous êtes dans une
salle et que vous montrez un cours à
distance et vous avez un tableau blanc
et bien il ya un mode spécial qui va
venir améliorer la lisibilité sur le
tableau blanc mais la chose qu'il faut
faire avancer poser ses petits marqueur
sur votre table blanc de chaque côté
comme ça ça permettra à votre caméra de
reconnaître l'emplacement de votre
tableau blanc il dira ok je vois ça je
reconnais c'est un tableau blanc je vais
optimisé totalement l'affichage dans
cette partie là donc ça aussi c'est très
bien c'est un petit quizz stark dit ok
bon tout ce côté là simple on a vu ça
marche autre accessoire peut être
intéressant c'est le tripode mini
tripote deux ans demain qui s'ouvre par
là avec des ciseaux c'est mieux voilà
donc le mini tripale hockey avec how to
use la notice et compagnie qu'est ce qui
à l'intérieur très bien 1 passe très
rapidement je fus donc à voir ça alors
ça il est comment il faut juste comme ça
de pouvoir se lever et de voir si je le
tourne voilà je le tourne disque lèvres
donc ça me parlait quand même devenir le
posé sur un bureau pour le mettre à côté
de moi evian le film est donc là il ya
un côté qui est vachement pratique
hockey petit trip hop ça marche ensuite
je vais avoir plein donc ça ça vient si
c est ensuite gimont pas de vis qui est
là pour venir le mettre dedans et j'ai
ensuite sains à l'intérieur ça sera bien
là et puis ça ça doit venir se mettre
dedans je pense voilà ça cette danse est
fixée une fois que ça s'est fixé je
prends ça je le mets dedans
je vis et ça me permet c'est presque
comme par magie ça me permet d'avoir ma
webcam qui est fixé sur mon pied que je
peux venir poser où je veux à côté de
moi c'est extrêmement pratique et après
regardez ça c'est cool aussi c'est que
je peux soit le maître comme ça alors il
sera à la verticale soit le décalé comme
ça soit le met un peu comme je veux donc
en fait ce qui est vachement bien c'est
la modularité si je veux venir filmer un
truc du dessus et bien je peux à plat je
viens de mettre comme ça et je viens
l'incliner donc là je peux filmer un
trou du dessus un peu un peu en décalé
parce que j'ai quand même le trépied qui
est là et puis après je peux bien filmé
comme ça je peux bien filmé comme ça
enfin bref c'est un peu ce que je veux
donc voilà ça c'est elles appartiennent
boxing bon reviens j'ai tout installer
pour vous montrer comment ça marche
c'est bien effectivement comme vous le
disais vous le prenez vous le posez vous
le branchez vous le mettez là dessus et
vous prenez un ordinateur c'est là que
ça devient intéressant et c'est là que
la magie opère je pense dans mon
ordinateur il s'active vous avez une
petite lumière là alors vous avez un
logiciel c'est celui-là c'est in stat
360 kling contrôleurs au louvre mac pc
une fois de plus je voulais vite c'est
très très pratique qu'est ce qui se
passe donc lui s'active il ya plusieurs
choses déjà je peux venir le piloter à
la main comme ça pour bien mettre mon
gameblog dans la position que je veux
voilà là je vais un peu sur la tronche
en fait là il me reconnaît parfois il
boit mais il n'y a pas de trac il n'ya
pas de suivi de visage en fait il ya
plusieurs boutons vous voyant pas dire
est ce que ça sera ma résolution voyez
je passe de résolution très hd jusqu'à
des formats un peu bâtard sur du full hd
et là j'ai carrément de la 4 4 ans donc
nous on reste maîtres sur l'a4 cas on
dit que la cathay qui nous intéresse ici
donc j'ai la 4k voix lors du calibre un
peu par rapport à la lumière comme bien
éclairé et tout le reste lui le voit
très très sombre premier bouton aussi
c'est le tracking là il n'y a pas de
tracking ce qui fait que si je sors
voyez il n'y a pas de tracking n'y a pas
de tracking n'y a pas de traquer le
trail king j'appuie maintenant il ya un
tracking on a connu mon visage on est
sur mon visage ou à venir zoom et un peu
sur mon visage si je me recule lui il va
venir résout mais sur mon visage et si
je me lève alors je suis juste au dessus
je suis là coucou voilà petit oiseau à
la la il fit donc là je peux me balader
chez moi je peux me déplacer donc là
j'ai un tracking donc quel que soit
l'endroit où je viens dans ma pièce lui
va vivre il ya d'autres options je vais
vous montrer par rapport au tracking
déjà celia zone soit on vient
effectivement prendre sur un plan de crs
esquif hélas non on peut choisir de
prendre qu'une partie du visage ou avoir
carrément pied en entier donc ça ces
voiliers pareil lorsque je venais là et
bien là il est un peu moins serré sur
mon visage il y un peu moins zoom est
donc comme ça et à pouvoir le suivre
comme ça donc ça ça dépend donc la voyez
je choisis directement half body zoom
donc là il va venir resserrer davantage
un peu sur moi voyez on le voit qu'il
est en train de doubler sur moi ou alors
je veux carrément un truc un peu plus
serré directement sur la tranche comme
ça et quand je vais me déplacer lui est
bien évident à zoomer directement à
l'oreille un croc paix dans l'image
attention c'est pas on n'a pas ici un
zoom optique ainsi un zoom numérique
mais ça c'est cool donc là c'est
vachement bien et puis vous avez un
tracking speed également là il est
normal on va pouvoir le mettre à fast
donc là il a passé ça va être beaucoup
plus rapide normalement lorsqu'il traque
alors c'est un peu plus dur à venir
regarder l'autre d'un truc qui bouge
aussi rapidement comme ça mais par
contre il ne perd pas donc il m'a tout
le temps quel que soit l'endroit où je
suis bon je trouve ça un peu violent
après on va éviter de se déplacer comme
ça mais ça qui est très cool vous mettez
en normal comme ça et il vient vous
suivre si vous vous jetez pas partout si
vous courez pas si vous mettez pas tous
les côtés normalement ça devrait bien se
passer voilà le principe voilà le suivi
voilà le trac donc ça c'est les options
un peu général ensuite vous avez
d'autres options vous avez une option
whiteboard c'est plus pour les
professeurs quand vous avez un tableau
blanc il va venir tout optimisé par
rapport à vos tableaux blancs je n'ai
pas de tableaux blancs ici donc ça ne
marchera pas donc on va pas l'avoir ça
c'est le premier truc ensuite d'y avoir
une autre option qui est intéressante
celle overhead mode alors l'honneur aide
c'est intéressant c'est lorsque je
prends ma caméra et que voyez donc la
voyez il va filmer sur le bas alors sur
le bas c'est quand même pratique parce
que je vois ça comme ça mais pour autant
j'aurais envie peuple a peut-être
devenir le décaler un petit peu parce
que si je veux montrer par exemple j'en
sais rien moi si je veux montrer la
boîte je peux qu on voit ma boîte j'ai
pas envie qu'on voit mécaloire mais
comme je peux encore faire encore un peu
un truc un peu différent en fait ce que
je vous recommande vraiment lorsque vous
voulez utiliser le mode overhead comme
sa part en hausse est de ne pas avoir de
pied et de le mettre soit sur un système
qui va vouloir d'avoir un bras un peu
plus long pour que vous justement vous
n'aviez pas votre pied dans le cadre
c'est un peu le seul truc c'est un peu
la limite mais il existe un mode dédié
c'est celui là c'est le overhead mode je
l'enlève j'appuie là je reviens et il me
reconnaît il est en face à moi coucou
mon petit lapin comment as tu fait voyez
j'ai bougé à mon truc donc j'ai bougé la
tête comme on est sur un petit bémol lui
eh bien il vient s'adapter et vient me
reconnaître et il va me suivre très
facilement donc c'est cool donc lâché en
mode tracking toujours le mode beast
view qu'on appellera le mode vue bureau
a traduit mais c'est ça l'idée en fait
la caméra un lorientais directement vers
le bas avec un angle de 45 degrés l'idée
c'est de venir montrer votre bureau
lorsque vous faites une vision que vous
montrez votre face up à fond on scrute
sur le bureau pour bien montrer un
document très facilement et vous
l'enlever et hop ça revient directement
sur vous comme ça vous avez vu un peu
les différents modes qui existe je vais
avoir la possibilité de venir faire des
captures d'écran très facilement voilà
j'ai une capture d'écran je peux lire
enregistré aussi directement si je
souhaite c'est assez pratique aussi donc
la voyait venir bouger mon guillemoles
par exemple si je veux mais tu l'as si
je veux aller shooté à autre chose si je
vais le mettre ailleurs très facilement
je peux venir afin qu'on sache un côté
très très très pratique et puis je peux
venir zoomer de la même manière et
ensuite voilà je peux venir des zooms et
très facilement hop et puis je me remet
ensuite vers moi parce que j'aimerais
bien retrouver alors un truc qui est
intéressant ici si vous voulez sur ce
mode là ce explique les différentes
positions là j'ai une position qui est
sur moi c'est la position 1 voilà qui
vient un peu sur ma tronche si l'on
vient de reconnaître si par exemple je
lui dis maintenant j'en sais rien moi
vingt films et les cartons derrière eva
zoom et un petit peu voilà je mets ça
comme ça et là hop la claque je crée un
précèdent deux comme ça j'appuie sur le
pré 7,1 il revient sur la première
position il ya sur moi ça c'est le
preset 1 et je veux qu'il aille sur la
position numéro deux hommes précèdent 2
effet tous directement il va directement
aux photos claque quand même vachement
pratique donc ça c'est cool ensuite je
vous montrais rapidement vous avez
d'autres paramètres qui sont très
intéressants pour venir modifier
compenser plus de luminosité moins de
luminosité la balance des blancs molière
faire soi-même bon je vous conseille
quand même de la laisser en automatique
pour éviter d'avoir des trucs trop trop
trop trop vite ou trop bleu comme ça
balance en automatique en peut venir
bouger un petit peu le brightness on
peut venir régler les contrastes on peut
venir changer la saturation est un petit
reset tout revient à zéro et puis après
vous avez d'autres paramètres qui sont
intéressants avec des gestes de la main
vous pouvez me réactiver les gestes
oncle âgé la main reconnaissance de la
main donc vous mettez la main il va
lancer le tracking alors il faut que
vous ayez votre main qu'ils soient déjà
dans le dans le plan dans le champ vous
la met à côté de vous vous mettez votre
main comme ça à côté de vous voilà elle
reconnaît voyait la nuit juste emballe
de tracking donc la sam activer le
tracking du visage donc ça c'est bien
alors je remets ma main il voit ma main
aux plages eulma côté là il le retirer
là je bouge voyez j'ai plus du tout donc
ça c'est intéressant haute mode c'est le
mode table blanche comme ça le v de la
victoire il le reconnaît mode tableau
blanc jeunes sur notre tableau blanc les
deux doigts voilà notre tableau blanc
est parti donc à plusieurs modes qui
sont sympas les zooms je vous ai montré
il ya un an ti flickr automatique ou pas
vous avez la vitesse du tracking
autofocus manuelle ou automatique alors
j'ai mis le streamer mode que je vais
venir décoché parce que le streamer mode
en fait il va servir lorsque vous allez
par exemple sur un obs lorsque vous êtes
dans le mode classique vous avez en
résolution wvga 4k
du hd du full hd et lorsque vous passez
en streamer mode avoir d'autres
résolutions qui vont arriver ici qui
sont plutôt pas mal regardez là je vais
avoir par exemple des modes un peu
bizarre je veux avoir du 1088 par 1900
avoir fait ça c'est du vertical jeu
permettra aussi de devenir stream est en
mode vertical très facilement comme ça
c'est plutôt pas mal et voyez par
exemple de la même manière sur obs mais
du coup je peux venir stream et je peux
dire le paramétrer comme je veux donc
construit mais c'est très très cool donc
ça c'est chouette sais pas si vous voyez
moi j'aime bien ce que le visage est
quand même vachement bien éclairé
température de couleur et très très
bonne il ya un autre cas connaître ici
c'est que vous avez le hdr alors le hdr
n'est pas supportée en cas de chaos en
60 images par seconde on va laisser sans
mettre en place je mets un petit h dr
donc bon à vous de voir si vous aimez le
hdr comme ça ou pas tous qu'elle
fonctionne très très bien sans âge
derrière comme ça et vous avez le
meilleur email ça va venir switcher en
face à avenir flipper comme ça si vous
voulez venir changer tac tac tac vous
pouvez le faire votre dernière version
pourrait mettre à jour très très
facilement si vous le souhaitez là je
vous ai montré tous les paramètres en
anglais mais il existe également en
français vous venez ici vous allez dans
préférences là vous avez votre langue
alors attendent impatiemment chinois on
se met en français en france et traduit
c'était plus pratique on aura le
contrôle du game boy on va voir les
différents modes là le suivi tableau
blanc mais en fait c'est la même chose
mais c'est traduit et ici les paramètres
d'image plus de réglages vous voyez
voilà c'est du français au lieu de
l'anglais mais sinon c'est la même chose
alors il ya un mode qui est intéressant
c'est ce mode là c'est le mode barre
d'outils alors le mode barre d'outils
l'intéressant parce que lorsque vous
avez un appel vous êtes sûr installer un
logiciel de streaming et compagnie est
bien la regarder vous allez avoir la
mise au point automatique votre petit
possibilité pour venir déplacer votre
bimbo la très facilement quand c'est
vachement cool le fait de pouvoir venir
zoomer dézoomer vos différentes celle
vous appuyer la fois ci sur la position
au passé sur la position de aussi très
très facilement vous avez le suivi vous
avez le zoom qui est là regardez le
suivi avec mes différentes zones
comprennent hier à retrouver ici le mode
tableau blanc enfin bref les différents
modes et là vous avez vos paramètres
pouvez retrouver aussi très très
facilement donc ce petit mot delà il
paraît tout bête mais quand on veut pas
avoir l'application en grand et que l'on
va utiliser une autre application par
exemple sur un appel téléphonique vous
êtes sur un web ex vous êtes sur un zoom
ou compagnie d'un pool utiliser ça
directement et c'est extrêmement mal
hein et puis voilà vous avez vu les
différents paramètres je trouve que
c'est très cool ça marque va se remet
donc là j'en ai une et je peux en avoir
une deuxième également si je veux venir
au stream et avoir une caméra sur le
dessus et avoir une caméra de face enfin
dans l'idée sur sa très cool vous voyez
regarder cette caméra elle uj très
facilement la tête là elle va venir sur
le haut donc là je me le suis mis en
mode ou c'est moi manuellement qui vient
le déplacer mais c'est il ya un tracking
un suivi automatique c'est vachement
bien vous vous en remettez pas en fait
vous posez votre caméra et elle elle
fait le taff tout seul vous embêter plus
posé plus de questions c'est vachement
cool alors les trucs à retenir ici c'est
la qualité l'image c'est la fluidité
c'est l'expérience et le fait vous le
posez comme vous voulez sur un
ordinateur ou pas d'ailleurs je voulais
pas montrer peser sur un ordinateur hop
gardez vous le prenez vous le posez
comme ça juste en haut de votre ordi
donc ça c'est quand même vachement cool
il vient se clipser extrêmement
facilement je te regarde comme ça que ce
sens là voyez il vient se positionner
comme ça il vient derrière sur votre
ordi prendre un appui à leur attention
sur un mac parce que vous avez bloqué le
capteur de luminosité quand vous venez
le décalé vous laissez pas forcément au
centre mais c'est très cool ça vous fait
une webcam pour venir travailler il ya
plein de software qui vont être
compatible avec honda microsoft ils sont
à skype en azoumana googleme ton art go
to meet you know webex wings entrailles
lifesize blue jeans vol meeting à la
plaint que je ne connais pas donc elle a
des tonnes pourrait venir utiliser
directement pour venir un chat et
compagnie si vous stream et de l'eau bs
et compagnie tout ce que vous voulez
très très facilement bref c'est une
super petite caméra ici super webcam qui
a lancé un stade 360 pour info ici le
gumball on est sur un trois axes donc ça
c'est très bien capteur d'un demi-pouce
je voulais dit vous avez également un
mode vie privée dessus le mode vie
privée c'est lorsque vous utilisez pas
votre caméra et au bout de dix secondes
lorsqu'elle est en mode veille et bien
devenir ce switcher vers le bas
directement tout en bas là comme ça et
l'idée est justement de ce mode là c'est
que ça va venir protéger votre vie
privée il n'y a pas de caméra qui va
être là vous n'avez pas à vous inquiéter
elle va filmer du rien parce qu'elle va
être complètement orientée vers le bas
et vous avez ici le trou focus qui va
venir faire le point sur vous c'est une
mise au point à détection de phase vous
avez deux micro antibruit qui sont
situées juste devant ici alors ce que je
recommande quand même c'est de devenir
utiliser un micro externe pour optimiser
à l'expérience et au truc est
intéressant si vous n'avez pas beaucoup
de ports usb c'est sur votre machine je
pense notamment aux macbook air et bien
vous pouvez venir le brancher à travers
un hub c'est complètement possible donc
ça aussi c'est très pratique le fameux
mode portrait dont je vous parlais où on
vient filmer également à la verticale en
est 16e ça c'est pas malin pour les
streams tik tok donc si vous êtes
streamers urgence à rien - youtube vous
avez le format rectangulaire forme un
paysage qui va bien et si vous êtes par
exemple sur tik tok hop vous passez de
l'autre côté en format portrait bien
aussi voilà pour cette nouvelle caméra
dins pas 360 c'est la ligne trouve hyper
canon c'est une très jolie découverte
pour toutes les personnes qui veulent
stream et qui veulent pas se prendre la
tête qui veulent avoir un tracking qui
veulent un suivi qui veulent un truc
très cool cette caméra est chouette au
moment où je fais cette vidéo je n'ai
pas de notion de tarifs je ne sais pas
combien elle va coûter la vidéo est
faite avant que le produit sort je vous
mets tout en bas dans la description
aller jeter un coup d'oeil et si elle
vous intéresse bien évidemment vous
trouverez un lien en bas d'un
description pour enfin payer pour
pouvoir l'acheter elle les accessoires
bref c'est très très cool merci à
in-stat 360 d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo d'âme à avoir permis de vous faire
découvrir ce produit que je trouve hyper
hyper canon très chouette que je
l'utilisé d'ailleurs moi pour venir un
stream et surtout bientôt une prochaine
fois on se retrouvera dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire que
dans quelqu'un vous pourrez l'utiliser
vous est ce que vous êtes plus streamer
est ce que vous êtes plus d'un côté
éducation professeur est ce que c'est
plus pour venir avoir une super webcam
pour venir converser avec des collègues
pour du professionnel dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
nous on se retrouve vite très vite très
très très vite pour continuer bien
évidemment par les tec une fois de plus
ce trésor découvert ce produit parce que
je trouve hyper canon hyper catholicisme
et là c'est chouette vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous votre avis ciao
[Musique]
et
pour
[Musique]